all right here is everything that you
need
to make a bmw key
first things first i'll go through the
price and and all that
you will need a laptop definitely a
laptop
it doesn't really matter the specs so
much but you do need a laptop
you will need i'll lay out everything
that i have here
so first of all high tag 2
version 3.1 bought from aliexpress so
it's a clone of the high tag
tool this cost me and everything's in
canadian dollars
the exact amount was 57 and i think 30
cents or something so 57.30
this is used to get the key blanks ready
so you will need high tag 2. the second
tool that you'll need
is a bmw explorer clone so this does
plug into your obd2 port
bmw explorer clone it also comes with
whoops
the uh the key security key it's a usb
stick but
they've uh they've
anyway it's a key whatever
that cost me 127 canadian
you will obviously need blank keys so
these are the keyless go
so they're the ones that uh their
comfort access plus
in other words you're able to have this
in your pocket
and start the car you don't actually
need to install insert it into the slot
these also come with a a blank
the blank key itself the blank blade
oops let me put that back in and these
cost
uh 18 a piece canadian
and that's shipped all of these prices
are are the shipped fully landed prices
whether or not you get hit by duties is
uh
to be determined um but anyway it's you
know
take a look and then finally so that's
everything you need to actually program
the keys
so the keys will work with these tools
high tag is used to get the key to first
of all read a key
you do need a key already so it reads
your current key
it then gets a blank key ready
using some of the data in your existing
key
and then bmw explorer is used
to now program that key that has now
been
been ready from high tag into the cas
module now by doing this over obd
2 i will tell everyone that you should
have a car
charger a 12 volt dc car charger running
at least
five amps to the battery to maintain
connection because the
the whole process takes about 15 minutes
or so to do in the car
and obviously if you're if you're poking
around and not too sure what you're
doing it might take a little bit longer
than that
and it does access different modules the
cas being one of them
so it will consume power your battery
does need to be maintained
up around the 13 volt mark so definitely
have a battery charger
and then this is a defu or defu
368a and it's a key duplicating machine
so you're able to put your key blade
your existing keyblade
in there put the blank in there and
actually make the key
this thing so these used to be
relatively cheap
i bought this for 178 dollars canadian
that's shipped that's a ship price so
all in with the electronics uh before
adding the keys the electronics
uh total was 184 dollars or thereabouts
and each of these are 18 canadian and
then this
you know 170 let's call it 200 bucks
all in so really 400
which is the price of one single key
at most bmw dealerships here in canada
so for the same price that you can get
one key made you can make
as many keys as you want really
so let's show you how it's done oh by
the way the hardest part
of all of this is you'll think that
these tools don't work
it's the damn drivers getting the
drivers and the software to work
you have to jump through hoops i'm
telling you right now uh
to get these things to actually work
with your computer
the drivers the drivers you have to go
on to uh
ftd website and download their driver
pack
you have to run some of these things in
compatibility mode
uh with the with high tag you also have
to because it's a clone
you have to set your date back to 2010
like december
4th or whatever 2010 you have to jump
through hoops
to get these things to work with the
drivers so i will tell you now
that these are not plug and play when it
comes to working with the computer they
do work
they work they function don't say that
they're they're
you know shitty things and they don't
work they do work you just have to be
really good and know what you're doing
to get the drivers to work on your
system for your system to recognize each
of these devices
once you do that you're good you're
golden uh but
that is the hardest part of all of this
getting the drivers to work
because it all is uh cloned and
imitation and all that
okay let's get into it okay
very quickly i've got an e60 key from a
bmw 530
in a 60 high tag 2 version 3.1
in high tag you want to read the ide to
confirm that the key can be read
you can then go into the advanced
functions click on bmw
you can take a look at the key info
so it reads it all so that's good cool
now we're going to do is we're going to
take out the good key
and we're going to put in
a blank key
just uh
sorry that's a case
there's a blank key
yeah just stand up there so again
completely blank key we're gonna get
this one
away from it and here we're gonna click
on bmw explorer
i can't start on programmer we'll be
prepared you want continue
yes so writes that old information to
the key
and it's done it's now written it as a
bec
file so now we're going to save that
back file to a usb
and put it into a different computer
that i will be
bringing out to the car
look a battery charger up i've got this
one set to
6 amps at 12 volts
right there all right i'm going to be
performing this in the car
i've got uh a chinese clone of bmw
explorer
and i've got their software here
so in an e60 you plug it in
down at the bottom and uh all right so
we're hooked up now
we got uh bmw explorer
the clone plus the key in got the tool
up here
i'm gonna go to quick test
it's going to scan it
cold as hell it's got my vin number
there it's got a model
all right so already the cas has popped
up right there
so i can actually stop this quick scan
seven faults in the cas really i can
open up the cas
which is here reads all my stuff
a whole bunch of crap in there
okay or whatever all good
um go down to extra options
down here sorry it is key learning
okay
i guess enough
keyring can take some time okay
doing stuff with the car
oh yeah it's got the keys coming up
hmm
still doing stuff
it's cold as hell by the way it's like
oh there we go okay so
all the slots are taken up except key
three this is my
original well i guess it's key three
which is all crap
and then i've got a blank key that i
showed you guys inside
it's the blank key and i already made
the file with high tag
so slot three i'm going to
press this green button here
it's going to ask me to load the file
which i have on my desktop
[Music]
somewhere right here it's a bek
file so i take my
a blank key and put that in
and i'm going to write the key
and it's going to be a keyless go
i pressed keyless go program key
okay wearing key recording can take some
time okay
see how long it takes
okay oh
it's doing some stuff
scary
right okay
okay
close close
close
okay let's uh
i'm gonna unplug it first
unplug the thing
all right so this is
oh baby
[Laughter]